Elon Musk just tweeted out he didn't
tweet it I guess he Zed it out he ex he
exed it out a video of a woman stuffing
a
2020 outdoor mailin ballot drop off box
so you can see here looking at here is
we pull this up same basic
thing it looks like the same Dropbox
everybody look at all those people doing
the right thing Wai W in line cut the
line so this is a maroon dress woman or
is this somebody else yeah yeah I know
that is that your that's look that so
this is a mule in front of everyone okay
sitting there watching like what so this
is happening right now as she opens it
up oh can't figure out to open up you
hear hear Charlie Charlie K's voice at
what point after the first now it's a
felony so this is a felon three felons
at one drop boox
everybody I want you to think about that
one after the other and the broad
daylight I mean now you could also get
driver's you know license plate Ino and
stuff right yes so she in broad daylight
while everyone else was watching just
violated Georgia law right yeah and so
Elon tweets this out and just says
H which is good
news I have from the beginning felt that
the 2020 election was a little bit dodgy
the moment I saw those numbers turn
coincident with the uh pipes burst in
Georgia and the the election overseers
being curiously shut out of some of the
precincts and the whole process of
counting being shut down for a few hours
in the middle of the night then going on
for days and weeks I thought you know
this election doesn't seem totally on
the up and up really from the moment
that the libs changed the voting rules
in some cases to violate the law and
state constitutions like in the case of
Pennsylvania and to enable widespread
mail in ballots and the ballot dro off
boxes I thought you know this isn't good
this is Rife and open for fraud as
Barack Obama said 10 years ago Barack
Obama before this scheme became
fashionable for Democrats and they
thought they could really win it Obama
himself and his team came out and said
oh no unsecured widespread mail in
ballots that's really dangerous that
opens up the possibility of voter fraud
then they realized they were very good
at it so so they've encouraged it but
this is big news not the not the fact
that these people seem to be cheating
but the fact that Elon Musk is promoting
it because don't forget the way if the
2020 election were rigged to the point
that that it were stolen that you got
that that had it not been so rigged
Donald Trump would have won some people
are saying well it was rigged but Biden
would have won anyway okay if it were if
it were rigged to the point that it
changed the outcome of the
election then
the chief villains in that story story
really are not the little election
workers or the people on the ground
harvesting the ballots and signing them
themselves and stuffing it into the
dropboxes the big villains were the
oligarchs in big Tech because it was big
Tech that censored damaging information
about Joe Biden that alone could have
thrown the election to Biden censoring
the hunter Biden laptop
story and it was big Tech that funded
this whole rigging don't forget it was
Mark Zuckerberg and big Tech who funded
the the schemes and the
organizations that were responsible for
the widespread mail and ballots and the
dropboxes in one case putting the
dropboxes illegally far away from the
county clerk's
offices so big Tech was complicit and
then the moment you raised any questions
about the election big Tech shut you
down canceled your account demonetized
your show did all sorts of things what I
don't just mean to single out Zuckerberg
it was all of them and now
finally we have a conservative running
one of the big Tech platforms the
smallest one but still a prominent one
punches above its weight because a lot
of a lot of Jos and people with a big
reach are on that platform formerly
known as Twitter now known as X so now
implausibly totally unexpectedly you've
got the the chief group responsible for
rigging the election as far as I'm
concerned big Tech has now been
infiltrated by someone who is more
amenable to conservative views and
desires and
who is questioning the election who is
violating their Chief Prohibition in the
days after the 2020 election that's
pretty good stuff we need to make our
elections
bulletproof and we need to make you
bulletproof too which is why you got to
check out bulletproof everyone right now
go to bulletproof everyone.com promo
code nolles kwes bulletproof everyone is
a premier American Body Armor
manufacturer and supplier designed and
built for everyday wear their unique
armor systems offer 25% more coverage
than standard armor while maintaining
flexibility and all day wearability
bulletproof everyone's ultra light armor
system is so light and thin you might
forget you're wearing it your safety and
discretion are their top concern unless
someone puts their hands on you no one
will have any clue that you're protected
with bulletproof everyone you are not a
walking billboard there are no visible
logos and no flashy designs they are
comfortable tailormade clothing system
that goes above and beyond adding
additional security by keeping you
Incognito and under the rate are work or
Play Bulletproof everyone who's got the
perfect armor system to fit your
everyday lifestyle and everyday budget
right now our listeners can get 10% off
plus a free bulletproof backpack with
the purchase of any bulletproof clothing
just use code nolles at checkout at
bulletproof everyone.com that's
bulletproof everyone.com promo code
nolles right now go to Jus cell.com if
you can believe it Thanksgiving is just
two weeks away just in time for the
holidays Jus cell is offering their best
sale of the year right now now you can
get 70 70% off Jus cell's most popular
package which now includes Jus cell 3
their newest under eye treatment genus
cell 3 will have you looking years
younger it uses advanced technology to
deliver complex vitamins and minerals
directly to your face for instant
hydration say goodbye to Fine Lines
crows feet under eye bags and dark spots
Jus cell will have you looking and
feeling your absolute best guaranteed or
your money back no questions asked our
talent manager Tessa absolutely loves
you using the genucel under eye cream
you deserve to look and feel your best
this holiday season I also just love the
founder of this company a Coptic
Christian from Egypt who left Egypt for
the American dream go to Jus cell.com
kwes to get this incredible holiday
discount for 77% off their most popular
package which includes the jusl 3 and
Dark Spot Corrector get results in 12
hours or less immediate effects are free
Jus cell.com
70% off plus free priority shipping jus
cell.com
NOS speaking of voter fraud there's a
lot of evidence of it there's a lot of
evidence of voter fraud guys and
consequential voter fraud there's a
judge in Connecticut Superior Court
Judge William Clark who has just ordered
the results of a recent mayoral primary
election in Bridgeport Connecticut
State's largest city to be overturned
and for a new election to be held so not
just well we found some issues but no no
no this election is null and void we
were going to hold a new election that's
how bad
the rigging was sometimes you hear with
with the 2020 presidential election that
well Trump's lawyers tried to make their
case in court and they
failed that mostly isn't true mostly
what happened is the Trump lawyers tried
to make their case in court and the
courts didn't want to hear it because
the courts don't want to get involved
because they don't want to be blamed for
picking one person or the other so they
mostly said n no thanks we're not we're
not interested see you later which is
what courts often do that's what that's
what the Supreme Court did in the 19
1948 senate election in Texas in which
LBJ a future president stole the seat
almost certainly stole the seat and the
Supreme Court said no we don't want
anything to do with it so we're talking
about a mayoral election here in
Bridgeport Connecticut where the stakes
are relatively low consider the stakes
for presidential election no one's going
to want to touch that with a 10-ft pole
but here in this mayoral election the
judge came down and said that
bridgeport's incumbent mayor Joe ganam
won the election as a result of
significant fraud and what kind of fraud
you guessed it fraud involving absentee
ballots the volume of evidence in this
case he writes including many hundreds
of hours of video surveillance disclosed
and accepted into evidence is perhaps
unprecedented in the state of
Connecticut in an election
case you've got video after video after
video as some are seeing in the 20
presidential election this this probably
only happened in Bridgeport Connecticut
right this this was probably
inconsequential right it could look
there's always fraud this is what you
hear from the people who
excuse what very possibly occurred in
2020 well look there's always fraud but
you know it doesn't necessarily swing an
election yeah but sometimes it does and
to swing a presidential election you
don't need to swing 300 million votes
you just need to swing a handful of
counties which will swing a handful of
districts which will swing the whole
election and then you look and you see
you've got certain bellweather counties
that generally determine which way the
election goes and you say hold on in the
2020 election 17 or 18 bellweather
counties out of what 19 went for Donald
Trump only one or two one for Joe
Biden does that make a lot of I don't
know but many because the the fact or
the the potential fact because the
hypothesis is so difficult to bear that
an election really could have been
rigged to the point of of getting the
wrong answer a lot of people will just
keep their heads down and say no no it
probably was okay it probably well now
now you're just sauntering into a
political buzs saww because yeah you're
not going to undo the 2020 election
where there's not going to be a point
where US Marshals lead Joe Biden out of
the Oval Office and they lead Donald
Trump in and they say sorry sir yes we
now know for certain it was a stolen
election and anyway you can undo all the
Biden stuff and hey there's not going to
be a war in the Middle East anymore and
there's not Russia is not going to
invade Ukraine anymore and we're going
to undo that's not of course and the
economy is going to be good again yeah
no that's not going to happen but if you
don't acknowledge the very plausible
scenario in which the 2020 election was
rigged in a consequential way then
you're you're not going to do a lot to
fix it before 2024 you're going to end
up in the same spot boy what a great
clip that was now hey hey hold up ring
that Bell subscribe to the Michael NS
YouTube channel we'll see you next time